my dear wonderful to have you with us as
always
so listen Candace
you and I have a lot of things in common
but one thing we have in common is when
the entire culture is saying one thing
like the culture might be right
sometimes it's right but our first
instinct is to say probably wrong
they're probably totally wrong and so
you I didn't even watch the making a
murderer series I only heard about it
but I just assumed if everybody's saying
this guy is innocent he's got to be
guilty as Sin and I know you actually
followed it very very closely and then
you because you're like a dog with a
bone because you refuse to let anything
like this just slip through the culture
you said uh no I'm gonna prove that this
jerk totally did it is that basically
how this project came about listen I
don't want to give too many spoilers
here but I will say that I obviously
have a fascination with the media's
ability to brainwash not just ever the
masses in general even us like I did
this sort of backwards examination of
why I used to support the lgbtq movement
and I only recently discovered that the
entire Laramie Project thing was a lie
yeah they've put on yeah they put on a
play at my school convinced me that this
gay kid for the simple crime of being
gay was tied to offense and killed it
was a complete lie a total media agreed
upon lies that they could further their
own agenda and so yes this project
making convicting a murderer which stems
from the Netflix series Smash series
making a murderer where everyone was
kind of very anti-police this was kind
of like white lives matter like before
there was Wildlife the black lives by
those white lives matter and everyone
just want to pay to the police and they
wanted to believe that you know this man
who was at one point in his life wrongly
convicted uh wrongly convicted of an
attempted murder that he did not
actually commit it was before DNA so
they wanted to believe that maybe twice
he just keeps getting himself into these
circumstances and Netflix seized on it
because they knew that they could just
manipulate people's emotions and make
them think that the a very aggressive
person his entire life story is
incredibly aggressive could potentially
be an angel so it was a fascinating
story to look into The Laramie Project
comparison is a really good one because
it also lets all of us off the hook
because I've been duped by some of these
things especially when I was younger and
it lets us off the hook a little bit in
that
I don't know what happened to Matthew
Shepard I'm just hearing about this guy
on the news I have no reason I guess not
to think that they're broadly telling me
the truth and then though like in that
case with The Laramie Project you look
into it and you see oh no actually the
fact that he was a homosexual is really
just a side part of the story there's
there's so much more here so why was the
story pushed in the first place it's not
because the media cared about a guy like
Matthew Shepard it's because they were
trying to push a broader social and
cultural agenda presumably they're doing
the same thing here I don't think they
actually care about this guy Steven
Avery but they do care about
promoting crime they do care about
undermining law enforcement and Law and
Order more broadly so I don't want you
to give away too many spoilers the show
should be a huge smash because it's
giving the answer the the reality to to
what Netflix was promoting but uh you
know give me a little taste like what
did you know what did you see here's
what I will say is don't be afraid to
eat some Humble Pie I think that's been
one of the greatest like things that I
I've always practiced humility I mean I
had everything wrong if you spoke to
Canada she was 18 a pro-choice Liberals
are good Republicans are racist and it's
actually been such an exciting thing
once you release that egotistical
element that makes you think oh I had to
have had it all right and you actually
learned the truth it's amazing it's
actually amazing because then it allows
you to further examine your psyche and
how your psych psychology is being
impacted and how the media really plays
the biggest role in this how your
emotions plus the media can just
completely disrupt your a true analysis
and this is a circus stance where you
have this man Stephen Avery something
did actually wrongfully happen to him
when he was wrongfully convicted before
DNA evidence was available of a
raping and leaving someone left for dead
she actually survived she pointed him
out and she said this guy did it she
thought it was him really thought it was
him and then they found out after 16
years that it actually wasn't him they
released him from prison he's not out
for prison long before suddenly he is
being convicted of another murder he's
being accused of another murder which
was the murder of Teresa halbach and
this inspired you know some Netflix
documentary makers and you're exactly
right you're going to see the same
characters again that were pushing this
idea that he was innocent let me say one
thing if Alec Baldwin ever tells you
that somebody's innocent they're
probably not okay it's a good rule of
thumb if Alec Baldwin and Trevor Noah
are getting behind something you are
probably taking part in a media
simulation and it's all the same Usual
Suspects and I think that people who
followed the story closely the tens of
million people around the world are just
going to be shocked at how far the media
will go to sell you an idea how how
often they omit facts because they
already have this packaged uh idea that
they're trying to sell you at the end of
it and in this circumstances that police
are rotten police are backwards police
are wrong police are corrupt and that
has really kind of been a media theme
for the last 10 years I saw even in the
trailer it that the documentary left out
specific crucial pieces of evidence
right oh yeah it's really bad I I mean
and what's I think most shocking is that
the documentary makers won an Emmy for
this and and it's interesting that the
amount of celebrities that I got
involved with this it pretty much like I
said if Hollywood's involved you pretty
much know that you're probably being
duped and you're being misled I have a
lot of questions about why Alec Baldwin
is always the center of all these things
but this became something that so many
celebrities were obsessed with and they
believed that this was like the
Innocence Project one of these Innocence
Project people then you look into it
you're like this person is innocent at
all why why are we trying to get this
person back onto the streets but this
one has been so long lasting there's
still a very dedicated Stephen Avery
culture so announcing this documentary
without even saying what our intentions
were to say we're going to re-examine it
people that are my fans have written me
nasty emails of like Candace I love you
I've supported you but this is something
you don't understand we've researched
this for for years for decades You
couldn't possibly know what we know why
are you so fearful I haven't said
anything yet you don't even know what
we're going to present to you chill out
maybe I'm going to come to the same
conclusion as you well because it's
scary to have to examine the possibility
that you've been duped and that's why I
say it comes with humility it comes with
you know suffering from cognitive
dissonance wondering how you could have
possibly been misled and I think that if
you're brave enough to go under that
Journey you're going to have a really
fun and interesting time looking into
this docuseries it's a really great
point because I'll even Zoom it out from
this case or any particular crime all
the way to political philosophy which is
when you realize that maybe liberalism
is kind of wrong
I remember when this happened to me in
college when I started to realize that
liberalism not just some crazy leftists
not just the most extreme kind of
wokeism but like just the liberal idea
might be kind of wrong that's extremely
disorienting it is when when you realize
that oh the media often don't tell you
the truth when you realize that
maybe in certain elections there have
been some Shenanigans and maybe it
wasn't all totally pristine when you
realize that maybe the law isn't applied
evenly to everybody maybe BLM gets off
the hook burning the country down for
for eight months and some Midwestern
Brandy gets thrown in the clink for for
January 6th you think wow
how much of what I've been told is not
true you know and it's it's why I have
so much grace for people who maybe they
start out as a leftist then they become
a fashionable libertarian type then they
become a more center-right kind of
conservative before you know it you know
they're to the right of Genghis Khan I
don't knock them for having been wrong
in the first place there's a long way to
go there are a lot of layers to peel
back here to realize how much we've been
told that isn't true you're describing
me right exactly yeah and I always tell
some degree me too yeah yeah and I wrote
about it in my book that I actually took
a year off to to suffer through real
cognitive business I thought I was going
crazy I mean it basically wake up one
day and you find out that up and down is
down is up it is completely
mind-shattering it is something that you
wonder okay am I insane are they insane
you feel weird because you've been so
strong and committed in your beliefs
like maybe you're the person that wrote
on Facebook I disown all Trump
supporters if you're a trump supporter
I'm you know unfriendly how do you go
back from that and that's that's humble
pill that I'm talking about that you
have to swallow and realize like hey I
was due we're all capable of being duped
none of us are above it I'm still
capable of being duped you know and I
recognize that now which is why I try to
pursue all of the facts before making
any of a determination because I know
that for the first part of my life and
this is in large part due obviously to
like you know low-income family public
school system I was totally apart I grew
up in Connecticut right you know so blue
and so I I really was just a victim of
my surroundings and also a victim of
what I believe to be a pretty nefarious
public school system and the education
system Department of Education that is
kind of renting us with these ideas this
is what's bad this is what's good you're
a black girl you're going to be a
Democrat um so I don't fault myself any
of that I think I would fault myself for
not having the courage to look at the
other side and then once I had once I
saw a little glimpse of the truth if I
was too scared and I shut the window on
it I would fault myself and said I
pursued it and you're right it was a
journey and I kind of was in the middle
and I was still holding on to some stuff
like oh well maybe it's okay to be
pro-choice and you know maybe gay
marriage is not all that bad and now I'm
like I make you and Clarence Thomas look
like Libs
pretty soon you might go all the way or
you're gonna end up a communist you're
gonna go so far You're Gonna Come Around
the other way so what's important about
this this series too I think is
it's getting into this very particular
case because we we can zoom out and say
oh what they're doing to Trump is bad or
oh you know immigration policy is better
so you know the 30 000 foot few but
lies like this in service of a political
agenda
they permeate everything they go all the
way down even to these tiny local
whoever the hell this guy is in a small
little case in the middle of nowhere
that happens much more frequently that
happens every single day so before I let
you go I'm going to try one more time to
just pull out of you all the secrets of
this doc so they're but I know you can't
we I want to enjoy it I don't want you
to spoil the whole series for me but
what can I look forward to I'll give you
all the spoilers right now you're broken
me down right here's what I will say I
think if we are taking a bird's eye view
it's just just what you're hitting upon
the real victim in this case was Teresa
halbach you were talking about a woman
who was in her early 20s just starting
her life who was fearful of Stephen
Avery who was found she well she wasn't
she was found in a burn pit she was
raped she was mutilated she uh was cut
up into a little pieces they had to use
her bone fragments to even put together
her DNA she had a devout Catholic Family
who handled this with extreme Grace and
because of the poisoning of the media
that family was attacked you know
because of people like Alec Baldwin a
mob of sent it online to tell them wild
conspiracy theories people that she had
like gone with the cows to Mexico I mean
the conspiracy theories that people came
up with because they refused to examine
the facts in the case and because a
Netflix documentary had led them to
believe that a man Stephen Avery was
completely innocent is shocking you know
it gets to a place of evil and I I was
left is really just thinking about her
and I wanted to make sure as we did this
docu-series that we also told the story
of the real victim in this case because
Netflix LED everybody to believe that it
was Steven Avery
um and that the perpetrators were the
police the victim in this case was the
young woman who lost her life in one of
the most horrific ways unimaginable if
you're a parent Teresa halbach and
taking you on that Journey there are so
many plot twists nobody even knows
anything about the Avery family no one
knows anything about Teresa halbach's
family they were also focused on this
narrow narrative and seeing all of the
facts around it I think is going to be
mind-blowing for a lot of people so
we're really looking forward to bringing
it 10 full episodes with me featured and
tons of other people including Steven
Avery's family we wanted to give
everybody a fair Shake wow I can't wait
is it all coming out at once or is it
going to be one of these drip drip drip
kind of things drip drip drip okay no
first episode's free it's going to be
available on X everybody can watch it
we're going to do this kind of live
viewing event and then the second
episode will be free on daily wire plus
and then I know by then you are just
going to want to binge on the rest of it
which will be available on daily wire
plus you're like a drug dealer you go
you give out the little taste the first
taste is free first taste is free I
can't wait take it I can't wait we'll
we'll see it will there will be the live
live viewing that'll be for everybody
and then then you come on into the inner
sanctum you get the real stuff Candace
my dear thank you I look forward to
seeing it always an honor Mr Knowles
foreign
[Music]